gang just want to remind you that the ru
garbage comedy special is on our youtube
page right now it is it is our favorite
moments from last year's tour and
speaking of doors we're here to announce
2022 the middle class famous store baby
new cities new trash new money yeah gang
we're coming to hartford albany syracuse
atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh buffalo
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago rosemont and this is just part
one plenty of cities coming after that
it's live stand up live auig it's a good
time get your tickets now we'll see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they got to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in antoni's
basement she's upstairs yeah hiding the
pills okay
she knows who's in the house
it's like an easter egg it's like a
dirtbag scavenger hunt it took me 45
minutes to find a tylenol i'm like jesus
christ
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me we got a little company in
the building a little family here he is
the ceo of are you garbage he is an
international businessman and he is not
to be trifled with in the board room or
bedroom or the bedroom give it up for kj
hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are
cooking baby i forgot t-bone doesn't
have a mic this episode um and then
obviously the greatest website of all
time patreon.com are you garbage you can
sign up you get bonus episodes ayg
episodes of hard feelings live streams
the whole nine yards check it the [ __ ]
out it's a party over there good stuff
we love you guys thank you so much for
the love and support and a nice shout
out even though we can't say anything to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man the brains behind the special he
makes us all look good we love them
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcgruffins
all right and the reason toby's off mike
this week is because we got we we got a
crowded house here
we have our incredibly special guests
both back with us again for the second
or third time but the first time
together they're in a hot new kitchen
got a little up there in queens they got
a little podcast called stuff island
that you gotta check out it's absolutely
fantastic we have uh chrissy cole
lasagna connor
and tommy two pops pope right here
please
good to see you fellas hey how you doing
good to see you too
thanks for having me now we could never
do that that was unbelievable yeah yeah
that was just i was a showman that's
right the boy's a [ __ ] show
unbelievable yeah taking turns
how many [ __ ] times i would bomb that
audition
i swear to god one time i had uh i
bombed an audition so [ __ ] bad it was
a final callback and i had a dude that
was from like uh london it was for a a
uh cell phone service and the whole
thing was i come out and he sit in a
chair and i say how great the deal is in
american
english
in america that's your first see what
language is this in american american
[ __ ] fantastic i'm even bombing the
story about boxing british what are we
doing i don't know what this has to do
with working with somebody else or
o'connor because eventually i'm saying
i'd be terrible what you guys just
pulled off and i bombed i tripped over
my words he never got it out he's
supposed to say the same lines in
british and it's still and it's supposed
to sound the same language yeah
[Laughter]
always looks like a disappointed hockey
coach
all right
he knows he's got the talent that's
icing
he's got the raw talent it doesn't want
to work
he's got a high ceiling he's got a high
suit
i'm just all stressed out because i'm
living with a strange family in michigan
at some boarding school anyway they're
all laughing
dude they're all laughing at me by the
way i could picture that house when you
said that this one director put a paper
over and he started shaking like a kid
who farts in the back of the school
and i go i'm sorry i'm on cold medicine
and it's really i just started lying the
roseanne bar thing
i had a zoloft you know i wasn't
sleeping so anyway i compliment you guys
on your intro all right the guy across
from you is auditioning too he's with me
so you [ __ ] him i [ __ ] him and then
i was like i hustled to the elevator and
it's one of those like pulled monkey
crates so he meets me in the elevator
again i was like i'm very very sorry but
about all that he's like sorry all right
it's hard mate hey he just looked like i
only flew here
and he had like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cookie this guy got dressed for
this i just smell like booze and drugs
that's probably pissed
cold medicine you mean yeah
[Laughter]
that goes further than you think i like
it anyway boys thank you for coming and
sit with us the podcast is [ __ ]
amazing yes thanks to you guys you've
both done it check out our episodes of
stuff island you probably already
watched them yeah yeah i hope so for
sure you guys are having fun doing it
yeah yeah it's great how's the creative
process going to tui
[Applause]
we both basically fight the whole time
but somehow it gets done yeah it's very
natural
it's even a more we have a very
complicated relationship yeah but ours
is like we you know like an old married
family publicly it's kind of we're a
united front you two on the other hand
are like fist fighting at the food court
you two all you two all have at it in
public you guys are a married couple
that [ __ ] on christmas yes once a year
yeah you still love and you still adore
the kids yeah we [ __ ] every night yeah
yeah but you guys are still tearing your
clothes off sure there's a couple of
domestics involved
real bonnie and clyde situation yeah
that's kind of why it works oh yeah it's
been going great thank you
man you two are attached together you're
both wearing black that's crazy good
yeah we went with the black he's he's
got he's on one today too don't get him
started what are you talking about
yelling at a fire truck on the way in
here
next to a [ __ ] mailbox fire truck
goes off how do you guys how did you
guys get into this the horn is for
intersections
the sirens are between blocks he doesn't
have for how crazy is he does make some
good yes there's cars in front of them
they hear the sirens we all hear the
sirens but they don't move you're
talking about when they go er
don't yeah you gotta give it to us
something's burning yeah i'll give
from connecticut where he's from i'll
give you two honks
honks oh yeah that was a little weird
but this guy was hitting 910 yeah all
the way down the street there's a fire
somewhere yeah but he's also driving
like 20.
[ __ ] ambulances and fire trucks they
they never push the limit i'm not sure
not sure if you've been reading today i
don't i don't see him screaming up and
down they're just [ __ ] he's like
i thought you were asking me if i could
drive oh man
i'll dust off the gloves for one last
job
i'll get a podcaster now but i'll do it
one rule no fire trucks
no did you guys i don't get out of the
way i go you follow me
yeah yeah
i see all the cone like this we start
getting out of the way i'm just like
sucker connie slides the siren on top
no you weren't driving when this was
happening that's what i'm asking that's
why he was standing on the street i'm
trying you know so how did you guys get
into the city today
we took it over took an uber okay but it
was way off and gone we didn't hold up
any traffic yeah they were dude they
were standing out front like they were
on a stakeout when i pulled up yeah my
[ __ ] tip of my my beak was chipping
by the time you got here ten minutes out
there boy holy [ __ ] is it called oh god
well how did you guys get here
i told you
imagine doing this he's a little pretty
i love him i love him but he's got a bit
of an edge
murder in his eyes how was your [ __ ]
christmas how the [ __ ] did you get in
would you what'd you [ __ ] like a fire
truck
how were you toby
i couldn't find it i couldn't think of
what it was but there was some clip that
you guys had from the pod of you were
yelling at him it was another weird
o'connor thing it was like the lasagna
in the in the in the refrigerator it was
something weird about food that you and
your family did but i was looking for
and i couldn't find it egg noodles
it was egg noodles what about the egg
noodles
you assault them you eat them
no he thinks egg noodles should be yeah
consumed on a normal basis
how do we feel about egg doodles i think
we talked about i've talked about it on
your pa yeah no they they're the ones in
the bag right yeah yeah
i'm a box pasta man myself
what's the difference between a box and
a bag a lot
cereal comes in a bag
parents that love you
about 48 cents at the o'connor house
apparently yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here what's the
difference between a hug and a handshake
all right there's a lot
two yeah
that's the real handshake what's that
a normal well-adjusted even being in a
psychopath
egg noodles egg noodles are a tough look
now you guys split an uber in right yeah
who pays for that uber we don't ever
talk about money usually i'll get i'll
get something i'll get a tab at a bar or
a restaurant and pick up you pick up
that's the way to do it you can't be
they do do good like that i don't [ __ ]
with people that probably money you know
like not problem as and i don't have a
lot of it but i'll pretend i have enough
to get that car and that [ __ ] uber
and not ask my buddy
for a couple bucks back you know what i
mean you ever see a table like five
friends of course split the checks yeah
why are you even eating should be
intimate that's just something that's
special to somebody you're gonna ruin it
bringing money up don't invite your
[ __ ] friend over to eat okay i'm with
you a hundred percent the guinea's
really coming out of him
when is sauce on a table you don't talk
money
i [ __ ] mean that dude cooking for
somebody or asking somebody out to go to
dinner that's an intimate thing where
like you expect a good time and you're
going to [ __ ] it up by bringing out you
know bringing up some money issues of
course so you know i waited tables for a
long time and used to drive me insane
yeah that's why i had hope in the future
generations when venmo came around but
they're still
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i caught it on the fire truck by
accident i thought you were in the hat
um
i was choking on my water uh we all got
covered wait who knows
you're hacking i got the antibodies i'm
good yeah i'm strong right now i can't
foresee you being a big vaccination guy
oh no i am oh really yeah yeah all right
i love science okay i can't get a read
on it i'm built i'm built i'm built for
the vaccine the va
my body takes science so well it's like
having a conversation with a shark
those eyes
a lot of times if i really need to get
something out i stare at his eyebrows
so that i don't get lost in this [ __ ]
evil look
halfway through i just go what what's
the matter goes nothing
i'm just listening to you yeah i'm like
you don't listen like that is something
wrong talk about it
what did i do just let me know
no i like to look through people yeah
you do man
that's why girls walk backwards
i'm gonna leave
chris oh dinner was fine
[Laughter]
you want to split the check
don't worry i got it
i don't want things to be weird about
money yeah your dinner is in no i don't
stare i don't stare at people
even that way
i don't stare at people yeah i think you
just get lost in your own thoughts this
is the most i've noticed this by the way
what how crazy you are yeah yeah while
the weekly podcast is really opening up
now that i'm forced to talk every week
it's really spilling out somebody
commented after like i i'm really i
think it was on like the post that i put
like
of your clip yeah and they were like man
i'm really seeing okay i'll really
legit psychopath
yeah yeah his takes are so [ __ ] wild
it calls it's the beauty of your your
show you're asking questions it's
immediate content you're always going to
come up with different perspectives
everything's hollywood over here all the
time that was a nice little that was a
nice little elevator picture every every
day everything's content that's what the
people want
tommy loves pitching and positioning
there he was bombing an audition
was it was the audition in london or
here that was here it was in one of
these i can't believe they gave you
eight takes at it
talented boy
they're like his face says he should be
an actor
give him another shot i don't know he's
a good looking we like your look in your
hair we hate your body
the way it's moving right now stop
shaking these two are great
they
really are
well you guys just said jim gaffigan in
here i know i know you clean the house
off does so
you keep plates and stuff like that in
your room no dude
i picture you i don't know
he doesn't use plates he doesn't use
napkins
he takes a [ __ ] sandwich that he
orders from ubereats or something yeah
slow walks it sits on the couch
unwraps it
no napkin well just eat like a monster
he eats like like a would you prefer if
i ran to the couch
okay that's what he's upset about
the speed that he wants to think that's
my issue
slow walking and then he takes a bite
puts it like right on the table raw and
then goes like this with his wait you'll
just put a sandwich on the coffee table
yeah
that's crazy no no not naked it's in the
wrapper
trust me you don't want to see it i mean
it's in the wrapper yeah give me that
exactly supposed to unfold the wrapper
and then you put your chips next to
yourself you get a sandwich you plate
the sandwich yes listen i i don't want
to get involved with this anymore it
really wears me the [ __ ] out if he took
this it'll finish it he'll put it there
and it really will never ever leave
so meanwhile everyone meanwhile every
morning
meanwhile
every common closet
is full of tommy's clothes
it's got a nice wardrobe she's got she
shoes everywhere i wear three shirts
yeah go back and watch all of his
pockets it's this one yeah and uh what's
the other one the hoodie with the
what's the other one oh oh
you got one pair of jeans what are two
sneakers that's just something that's a
bar yeah i don't know they gave it to me
anyway
you're a free shirt guy you are oh yeah
yeah yeah you don't buy clothes a lot
no in fact every time i buy jeans it's a
whole [ __ ] where do you go fashion's
fashion's changed completely every time
i have to buy jeans he's wearing bell
bottoms yeah
yeah there's no chicks out here
i've been tripping over these jenkos for
[ __ ] hours yeah
it's got all this podcasting equipment
in the back pocket i'm like what numbers
what number is levi's on
what's a chris o'connor's shopping
experience they don't put the ass flap
in the back anymore what the hell is
going on here where are my suspenders
well are you going to like an h m a
macy's a gap what are you doing uh last
time i shopped i hit a j crew and i had
tommy tommy on the phone the whole
connecticut in yeah the jay crow's a
little bit he sent me a pics and i
picked out his name you're a j crew man
i just haven't got any crew here and
there it's a little over it's a little
overpriced for what you get
quality wise is there tommy does dress
good you've always been put together for
even like how unsuccessful you've been
at period like we've all been at periods
thank you he would show up to open mic
to like italian boots what was that
about yeah
what the [ __ ] was that about
are you getting me back when i said on
your on our podcast no what i really
opened up i was trying to compliment
your podcast and i was like i get the
thing oh yeah and you're like you don't
miss it
and the food and the stuff yeah yeah i'd
be good on your show you didn't say that
he liked it he said i i get the whole
thing yeah i get the whole thing with
the hand wave that was very dismissive
is that what you were doing because that
seemed like a shot is that what you were
getting back that's the thing i get from
my father
no no no i get it oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you'd show up like in a [ __ ]
three-piece suit mostly like because i
was coming off a real job in a real life
but i forgot what it was like to be a
[ __ ] zilch
i mean i basically was the only he was
the first guy i knew with a peacoat he
had to have he had to have the nice
clothes to keep everything to keep up
with appearances everything moving when
he's out at the bar
once you leave a hundred thousand dollar
job and then you're [ __ ] a park in my
car in the in the lot next to helium and
then i hang out with a bunch of bed bugs
you know what i mean i was talking to
you in the front of the raven one night
and he's like you had just left your job
to go full-time comedian in philly which
is tough i mean you're doing like shows
at applebee's giving me anxiety and he's
like no no he's fine he's like yeah we
just hang on we're talking you're
talking in front of in front of the
ravens
no we're in the bar at the raven at the
front like at the window okay or you see
that little like half ball like by like
that window the vestibule yeah and we
were cool we were going out i think what
he had just done is a big rail yeah
don't bring that up
we gotta stop
it was a lazy susan that would then turn
around
and they would take the five dollars and
replace it with a pbr and then turn it
back yeah you'd go to the bathroom and
order a beer at a pretty special place
there was just a guy in a broom closet
back there with a cooler filling it up
smelling dumps once in a while
uh no but you're like wait i was just i
was like how do you even do it and
you're like you just got to find bars
that'll give you free booze i'm like oh
this guy's this guy's nuts yeah his his
tips were success on how to make it with
bartenders who will give you he goes
yeah place where you do shows at oh boy
you drink for free you know what i mean
just dip them pretty good you drink for
free that's really good find a place on
monday come back come back come back on
the weekend you'll be all right this is
true meanwhile i was in like a 400
trench coat i'm like okay mr pope
well you can't be bopping around like
different bars you got to find one ball
and you got to know these two you are
very loyal i went to that place with you
guys in queens last week man they walked
in they were like tommy yeah yeah you
take care of them they won't charge you
the beer all the tip money goes right to
them and then you fill out if you feel
out of cycle kip let's talk about all
forms all form yep you think you might
not know it but you do know it it's a
helix company it's a helix company helix
is now out of the bedroom and in to the
sofa game
with all form you gotta check it out
absolutely fantastic you won't be
steered wrong yeah guys it's the easiest
way you can customize the sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores we got one
right over there right there hoodie got
one they sent it here many a nap on that
thing i put it together by myself it's
like putting together a [ __ ] lego set
it's easy peasy easy uh
you can do it by yourself all different
colors finishes whatever you want
pillows sectionals and the best thing
about it is if you change apartments you
get a new roommate or whatever you can
get a you can extend it you just keep
adding to it pretty sweet
um like i said we love it big fan it's
it's the only couch here at tooties it's
nice called her passed out smoking a
cigarette the other day careful
uh all form also has financing and
flexible payment plans so an amazing
sofa is never far away they even offer a
forever warranty literally forever wow
to get your perfect sofa check out all
form.com garbage all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allforum.com garbage one more time all
form.com
garbage do it kip let's talk about black
buffalo baby blick buffalo you know i
got a lot of folks out there like to uh
you know how do i say this uh pack a
lipper a little chewy pack of dip you
don't know what i mean yeah packing lips
hey listen when you're young
whenever get older you gotta get away
from that stuff uh-huh but there's
alternative to everything these days and
black buffalo can help yes if you're 12
if you're 21 or over and you dip or two
tobacco pouches are long cut don't
matter you have to try this tobacco
alternative black buffalo uh try it
it's everything you love about dipping
include the uh pharmaceutical grade
nicotine just without the actual tobacco
stem or leaf there you go they sell
their products at blackbuffalo.com it's
available both long cut and pouches if
you're looking uh to ditch nicotine and
tobacco tap into their nicotine free
options called zero they got you covered
look at that you want it you don't want
it they got your subscription comes to
your door the flavors the whole nine
yards kind of set it in forget it type
thing what gets it for me
born in the midwest raised in the south
these are good old boys down there black
buffalo proudly manufactures their
products right here in the us of hey
local no cons
you know what i mean
uh
they they sent us it i have we've tried
it so check it out
uh it's a new year and if you are one of
the 10 million people who are 21 and
over and dip tobacco consider turning
over a new leaf and switching to black
buffalo it's everything you love about
dipping just without the actual tobacco
stem or leaf
uh head to blackbuffalo.com use promo
code garbage for checkout for 25 off
your first order nice that's the best
offer you'll find but if you have to use
our code garbage for 25 off your first
order one last time promo code garbage
25 off your first order do it yeah
is he now is he now starting to ride
along oh yeah
yeah
yeah yep what do you two do on a normal
night well when i was there i could i
can
o'connor pooped at the bar
oh my god tommy i threw up tommy went
into the bathroom it smelled so bad that
he then threw up in the bar the next one
the next bat there's two bathrooms next
to each other
he just came out this was just after we
had a podcast going you don't [ __ ] in
public you don't you this there's never
a reason outside of eating raw chicken
you should never be dumping in public
you shouldn't waste your time [ __ ] and
puke yes that's my point we gotta get
you to a doc no
something's not right down here dude it
was like the reptile section of the zoo
it was simple
i gotta get it on newspaper it's like
getting hit in the face with a [ __ ]
shovel
i can't i just started dry even i threw
up in the next the next uh wait what do
you mean you don't poop in public you
don't poop in public never that's insane
it isn't you figure out your own
schedule and you work around that and if
you if if you have something set when
you normally go in your bowel movements
you you move your schedule around that
if you've got to go
what if you go to like a music festival
grow up
you don't okay
you get a job you're not 18.
yeah what a weird thing to say man well
port-a-potties
oh port-a-potty's like a football game
you're sitting at a football game oh
[ __ ] if i have to [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] i
mean he didn't [ __ ] at a bar and there
was four people in the floor yeah
he was she was he was 25 of the patrons
he got up and left for like 45 minutes
and i'm like where the [ __ ] is o'conn we
had done like four shots i'm like where
the [ __ ] is oh connie well it's either
that or i have to leave i get i'm not
opposed to it i understand when you're
hemmed up you gotta you know you gotta
take care of it i didn't i didn't
realize tommy would go in there and
intentionally smell it
intentionally yeah you was only two man
you knew exactly what happened in there
you went in there to smell it he does
that all the time he smells i respect it
dude
the first time the first time i was able
to go away and stay go on vacation with
my friends family all right real nice
place down the shore they had [ __ ]
grandparents imagination brother and
sister yeah i'm like 12 year old oh i'm
like 12 years old i'm real insecure real
low have some more macky geez please
not until your shirt dries off
you know
you know he's pool hopping with a shirt
on
no you can't wear your wet clothes on
the couch henry
you're not going to get the security
that's a [ __ ] disgrace to fat kids
you always take your shirt off you fat
kids out there you [ __ ] bite the
bullets yeah show them who you are never
go in there with a t-shirt on i did it
once or twice probably around 11. and
the second i got it like it makes that
suction it's a condom i'm like this is
bad it's crazy it's crazy it makes your
titties look even worse
or better anyway i get we get down there
first night all right
and i had a [ __ ] poop really bad and
it was like a little short house so the
[ __ ] bathroom is right off the living
room i'm talking whole family the
grandma the grandma the mom the dad the
hot older sister everybody's in there
we're all watching [ __ ] tv or
whatever it was i go in there and dump i
come out like 15 minutes later try to
blend back into the couch you know what
i mean like i was starting laughing or
something i tried to hop in the story
i was here the whole time
came out with a play-doh hot hors
d'oeuvres
it was hungry puff pastries yeah just
slide us frozen
just to be a dick
[ __ ] goes in the bathroom and then
comes out and goes oh my god henry
in front of the whole [ __ ] family and
i haven't [ __ ] so did they laugh
did they laugh no
see that's [ __ ] those people yeah no i
agree with that
[ __ ] those people people take [ __ ] no
they felt bad for me they were like what
the poor yeah yeah
it's all about the toilet the courtesy
you have to flush as soon as things
happen i let it out
that's it let it out flush then you'll
wipe it clean up disgusting connie i
imagine you wanted this you want it you
want everybody you want everybody to
know no i'm not demanding i'm not trying
to push it on people
i'm not trying to be able to get people
to smell it
but it's just like it's a it's a natural
human thing
sure you're gonna get mad because you
smell some farts [ __ ] you
it really bothers me it really bothers
me it's just like dude this [ __ ] happens
we'll get over it i understand so is
that a typical night
do you ever have someone getting no i'm
shooting at a bar then we almost got
into the fifth
and then we usually go to the bar down
the street for a couple pops with the
guests and then uh
and [ __ ] off home yeah he usually edits
two three nights a week
we got this how many nights you're going
out together
four or five
yeah yeah yeah we're close yeah
this is all good yeah we have a good
time we have a great time yeah
it's fun keep your bowel movements
[ __ ] we really hit it off
no more shooting at denny's i'll tell
you that again
also you were about i forgot we didn't
matt you were about to steal that drink
that night you were you were about to
steal the pint glass do you remember
that no yeah he was walking out of here
about a half a pint glass and he goes
all right i'll see you later like you
like all right i'll see you and you had
it and she's like all right see you
tommy and i saw your conscious kick in
and you're like okay i'll see you that's
what it looks like yeah and then cleaned
up the glasses because you felt bad i
don't think i did that
are you like my steelers
i've stolen pine glasses sure
yeah habitually though
no no i i used to do it from the place
bards in philly because they had those
nice little pull up glasses
they had some real interesting toilet
glasses with brand names on them so i
put a couple and i hated the [ __ ]
bartender i hated them yeah and i hated
the bar so i was like yeah [ __ ] you you
know yeah i agree i'm gonna take a
couple of these home
do you steal anything else
no steal i can picture you stealing
you'll get a convenience store stealer
like a 401k i can't stand i don't
[Laughter]
i got a couple of scams that i run what
do you got apparently what well the
group a board group won what oh yeah he
told me about this what came in handy
regardless of what group you were in if
you just board group one
how you just just walk on you just
ignore it yes
and they scan your ticket it's very odd
that they'll say sir we're just sporting
group one right now you're group three
yeah there's probably a thing if they
scan it
no they gotta let you in they always
that's what i'm saying like you can't
like scan it and then go like that then
that's it you're bored no i got shut
down once after they scanned i tried the
board
for group two and i was group like five
oh man and she's like you're not you're
not ready well there's some there's
always one person tough group yeah
that's what i usually have dudes
we're still wiping that section yeah
go to our patreon get me to group two at
least yeah check out their patreon i'm
always group seven
seven there's no [ __ ] i check in an
hour before the flight
is that what that has to do with yeah
it's just when you check
when you buy it's your ticket yeah it's
what ticket yeah what level of dirt bag
you want well group one you can't if you
group one is like select people but i
think groups like three through seven
are
kind of like when you check in
that might be like if you check in late
they dump you out why don't they just
put [ __ ]
the back of the plane to the front of
the plane well they started doing that
during covid because the front of the
plane people pay more yeah they get on
first they want to see the overheads too
why do they want us they're already
sitting no they it's the overhead space
because if you're in the back of the
plane oh you run out over and they check
your back plus if i'm if i'm paying if
i'm paying for first class you want that
seat they want you want them to see you
i want them to [ __ ] see me
[ __ ] fat ass same people judging you
in line
this guy probably bought two seats
i'm doing my part yeah i really hand it
up i gotta i gotta go sideways the bag's
over my head my tits are hanging out
i really they really get their money's
worth sometimes they ask me to walk back
so they can feel better send that fat
kid up here again
this time get some champagne
remember that one lady made fun you
asked for the seatbelt extender and the
one lady made funny that was mean i've
made a lot of fat jokes at your expense
what'd she say i don't know it was
something like oh yeah of course or it
was something you were like oh god
you're like that [ __ ] [ __ ] she
[ __ ]
she shamed you yeah i think so i can't
remember what i forget what the line was
but it was like uh i don't know but i'm
suing she chuckles shout out let's get
this [ __ ] cancelled
i forget
i just want free cookies
those are dynamite the biscotti
no is it this golf yeah biscoff yeah
that's the brand right they're like
cinnamon yeah they stink oh i love them
they're terrible i love it and i found
out you can order them scotty and
gentlemen now we're taking a flight just
order a box right from the company hold
on slow down i kind of don't like
anything
what do you mean
the company where'd you get away
you can order biscoffs from directly
from the uh the pilot drops them off the
biscoff factory
it's a company like jesus
it's not delta didn't buy the company
they they just you it's it's owned by
hudson news yeah
it's an organization that makes cookies
in a factory and it has the contract for
delta yeah that's all it is yeah mr
biscoff was like how many do you want
he's like you've never seen those and
you can just order them put some inside
people at home that want them tommy you
can just get them in a store you don't
gotta get on the plane that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm telling you
you're saying you ordered i think you
think i think you think delta owns this
flying crosstalk for a couple of cookies
am i [ __ ] up here now hold on a second
pick any of this up we gotta go back
what's your [ __ ] problem with
biscotti it tastes like [ __ ] yes
it's like rich it's like rich european
kids you're crazy give me give me a
[ __ ] give me your chips ahoy yeah i'm
an entity
i'm a [ __ ] american a nice chocolate
covered biscottis nice what are you
talking about you dip it in your coffee
gentlemen
a little dip real quick into a cream
coffee because i i used to like stella
dora breakfast treats when i was yeah
i almost bought a bag yesterday yeah
it's all different multi uh flavored
they're real old-school [ __ ] with the
long bars no no that's biscotti
that's biscotti but you know what
stelladora is a mixed stellador is a
company it's got like they
uh frostings and [ __ ] on it it's like uh
flavored stelladoro yeah
that's them oh get out of here that
shit's no [ __ ] hey mussolini kick
rocks all right
that [ __ ] stinks i've never even no way
would that does that fly in my household
wait hold on hold on those things no i
think the margarites i think the
margarita that whole brand is a no-fly
zone yeah yeah yeah it's the brand they
have their own little aisle they have
their own little thing
there's no way the peace was buying out
of his life there's no packaging
and [ __ ]
get out of here
we're just in an entire oreo right now
oh dude we used to love them i don't
like cannolis either
yeah i could have saw that coming
[Laughter]
out of a child what are you talking
about
children love cannolis yeah they should
it's a very nice cookie what did you get
when you were a kid you didn't have nice
cannoli when you were a kid like a devil
dog all right all right that's not a
double dog the devil dog is that the
chocolate one with the green chocolate
with the cream that's all right
i like a regular enchantment's coffee
cake oh
yeah
honeycomb
wait honeycomb cereal yeah yeah yeah
you like it guys
this guy's jumping category well he got
so nervous about having a third option
you strike me as a dry cereal kind of
kid sit there and eat cereal dry like a
psycho no i soaked the [ __ ] [ __ ]
sugar pops and the black coffee
kind of grapefruit sugar pops the only
cereal i ever ate dry was uh regular
cheerios
like a little snack pack yeah in a bag
yeah
when you were six months old
yeah i was a baby too
no i had two teeth he also didn't have
teeth yeah no i just i yeah
you know
i can't make anything yeah yeah i can't
take at the time
so i just eat regular if you check out
our cooking show so yeah run what is the
cooking show it's just it's chris and i
in the kitchen pretty much following uh
following me cooking and chris being
crazy yeah yeah and every now and then
christine without
yeah yeah yeah he does you don't know
how to cook at all
no i i do if you if you set me to a task
i do it pretty good well we are this is
how the chicken parm first episode i'm a
good cheese grater
oh yeah he can he can he can offer
services he doesn't know how to cook
yeah yeah like i can't
yeah
no you say
yeah he's just
he's my [ __ ] foreman you know what i
mean she's yeah okay yeah so if i only
is johnny on the spot in the kitchen
he's holding the flashlight and you're
that can you make it yeah
yeah oh connor can you make eggs oh yeah
okay yeah i can make egg i can yeah i
can make eggs i can make pancakes i can
make you can make pancakes i can cook
you baby i made eggs once in the house
you've been there two years yeah yeah
well i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna show off my snails
i can make them i don't want anybody
ripping off my style
yeah
i'm working on a cookbook no i don't
like cleaning up and now it's even worse
because you know yeah so what do you do
for breakfast you wake up in the morning
what time you i peg you was like a
nooner you get it i feel like social
services should be called or something
yeah i was like you guys should get just
wellness
i was getting up at like nine or ten
there for a while
now workload depends on the night load
yeah yeah we've been boozing it up quite
a bit we had a nice we had a nice happy
run with the start of the patreon where
we got excited and watched editing you
guys
i remember shane coming in one night and
he was like yeah i read this book
because he like he was
experiencing the beginning of the start
well it's like you know yeah you're
finally having like success starts a
little bit you two are still catching 5
[Laughter]
there's a pac-man machine behind you
that's the thing you're both sitting in
race cars
no he's he's gonna you're gonna get
fancy as [ __ ] probably i'm still gonna
be sleeping on top of my laundry yeah
but no it's a very simple ideal idea
that it's been done a million [ __ ]
times but uh you know the concept i have
is like no one's really married comedy
and cooking appropriately and correctly
so where you're giving advice in an
entertaining way that's like both
informative you know funny as [ __ ] i
hope at some at certain points and then
also like fun to watch yeah cooking in
the background of any any house is like
always just
fun to to do and absorb i guess
it's going to be on the stuff file on
patreon yeah yeah right now it's because
it's it's a lot of work for chris
there's three camera setups the edits
john nunn's helping us you need a t-bone
you need to we do need a t-bone you need
an editor he's not for sale yeah yeah
yeah
we got a couple guys that we're that
crazy yeah
yeah so it's once we get two or three or
four episodes out i think we'll have an
idea of like the theme the format it's
going to take some growing pains and i
just i think people are going to [ __ ]
like it because yeah
i've consumed so many hours of [ __ ]
cooking shows yeah that i know what's
missing in terms of just a unique flair
or like just tommy [ __ ] hollywood
dude honestly he is good i have no
what's missing tommy's good in the
kitchen too he's good in the kitchen i
saw him i saw him you made a short rib
one time blew my socks off yeah that's
really nice he's got the good stuff he's
got the good you got a nice knife though
you were flashing out good night you
spend a lot of money doing quarantine
yeah literally all my savings online i
want to talk to you i want to pull the
trigger on some kitchen stuff yeah you
have you have those you have those
colored pots yeah the luck luck crusade
yeah
yeah they they're lifetime pots
what do you mean
that'll never chip it's a non-stick
surface pretty much and the the the cook
the concentrated cook is is all the way
through the iron it's not like you never
have burn spots really yeah it's fluid
all the way through top to bottom side
to side this is the kind of stuff you're
going to get
yo dude i'm vodka you know what happens
you're like i'm pretty sure he knows
what he's talking about also maybe not
okay let's talk about ladder ladder
let's talk about the uncertainty of uh
of the world today these are wacky times
we're living in they're wacky kooky
times need a little bit of a safety net
need a little bit of a safety net a lot
of people get scared away term life but
you want to get yourself some insurance
you want to make a term life and you
want to take care of the ones that you
love yes ladder is 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for 3 million in coverage or less
just take a few minutes on a phone or
laptop
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time to find out if you're instantly
approved no waiting around look at that
no driving to some bozo's place you know
a strip mall or anything uh and you can
finally uh life insurance costs more as
you age now is the time to cross it off
you make a move baby no hidden fees
canceled any time it's easy peasy uh
ladder policies are issued by insurers
with long proven histories of paying
claims they're rated a and a plus by am
the best
it's nice pretty good i think not too
shabby uh more of an fm man myself so go
to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it tip
athletic greens athletic greens athletic
greens we ain't talking athletic blues
baby let me tell you something i saw an
ad for them somewhere else before they
became a sponsor yeah and i was
intrigued you were all over it and then
when i found out that they came on board
and sent us some yeah i was
knocking on my door looking for the
stuff i've taken it every single day
since we've had it i'm i haven't had
coffee yeah all right
gut health
immunity
energy
basic nutrients absolutely fantastic
tastes great too i can sit there and sip
it it's not something i have to pound
down i can sit and sip it yeah maybe on
the rocks or something that's a great
taste man i'm telling you all right yeah
guys it's lifestyle friendly whether you
eat keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten free uh ag one's got you covered
uh tons of people take some kind of
multivitamin and support and choose one
with high quality ingredients that your
body actually absorbs and ag-1 has it
covered they got even little packets for
if you're on the go uh it costs less
than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit you
got there you go um athletic greens has
over 7 000 five-star reviews recommended
by professional athletes trusted by
leading health experts such as tim
ferriss and michael jervis gervais
take that put that in your pipe and
smoke it there you go put that in your
green juice what else you need to hear
um
right now it's a time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into cold and flu season
absolutely just one scoop in a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills all over the
place supplements um to look after your
health but they give you a cool bottle
you shake it up it's right there that's
they got a cool package athletics is
going to give you
a free one-year supply of immune support
and vitamin d that i kept and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athletic greens.com garbage to take
ownership of your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance now
back to the show yeah
no tommy literally is like
you can tell he's been doing this show
in his head for probably three years
well i've also got a lot of shows going
on since i was a kid it's like and i get
i get chris eyes i get this crisp beady
[ __ ] psychopathic eyes when i start
talking about it because i'm so intense
about it and i just i think there's a
there's a misconception about high-end
cooking uh that low-end people can't do
you know what i mean there's like classy
dishes that they think the trash can't
do and the trash people like i would
never attempt that it's like sure
there's this middle ground i like it
it's not even touched i like this and
you could do these these dishes like
that short rib ragu that if you took to
a party or a
holiday people were like [ __ ] blown
away and it's simple it just takes a
little effort a little time a little
precision and you'll never forget the
[ __ ] fish yeah yeah [ __ ] gary vee
in the kitchen anybody can do it just
start cooking i just i talk like a
[ __ ] like this i just i'll give like
you have never been to the type of type
of party you're describing
the last time i've had like something
like barbecues out back it you know i i
treat my comedy friends like of course
like i always would have won it at a
family party sure instead of like about
a bag of pretzels i know but you like
chips and a napkin you painted it in a
napkin that's my childhood that's it oh
yeah and then like a deli meat that
would sweat like my fat uncle that would
just be laid out until people just
thought you couldn't eat it because the
cheese got bad it's like no that's when
it gets good you [ __ ] i remember the
first time i had wet cheese i had
karen's house so it was like 92. i'll
never forget that feeling that's the
solidified fats uh uncoagulating
sometimes it comes to the surface and
opens out my favorite platter was not
with a not like i like a hoagie tray
yeah but back in the day yeah but it
wasn't primos it was like [ __ ] wawa
or some dog [ __ ] like spring shop
writers sure yeah they did all right
though but what i'm gonna say
i did all right i like the one that
wasn't that wasn't made when it was the
slices in a row yourself a couple there
was always a couple slices of rye bread
and there was no mayo
straight mustard no lettuce tomato real
old school yeah i'm actually gonna do an
italian honey uh probably the next like
month because there's there's certain
ways to make a really high-end hoagie
that that you won't have to worry about
ordering anymore i'll tell you this
about new york there's no good [ __ ]
there's no good coffee
a really high-end
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah he was all [ __ ] yacked out doing
the crack with some hooker and she bit
his tongue with him i didn't think it
was red bull
[Laughter]
well we all know you don't end up biting
[ __ ] there's no there's no way we
live in a story where there's all the
different cultures and cuisines which is
wonderful but there's no american
comfort food on that you can rely on
there's like two places that have a
decent home stinks a decent hog no queen
alley queens that's not what i'm saying
is nice
philly
it's by far we've had this conversation
on the road by far the greatest sandwich
location station it's great yeah i mean
you there's there's two or three places
even in the suburbs just a place you
know
what are you talking about you spent two
years
you you also never you've been there for
20 years
jersey mike zipping what are you talking
about [ __ ] low life get out of here
i'm just no you're putting american
cheese on an italian sub i can tell
you go to any [ __ ] neighborhood
around philly every anybody says
all right i'm not putting cheese on
anything
somebody else is putting it on
and i'm buying it
he no no i'm not making myself one of
the things this animal does and then
we'll move on i'm sorry about talking
too much
he gets a podcast no let's be silent
what the [ __ ] tommy tommy we're not
defense he gets a bacon this is our
192nd episode keep talking
we're gassed
it's not true he gets a bacon egg and
cheese when he gets up or whatever and
then he only eats half and then he puts
the other half in the back
where he does his editing just lets it
sit there and you he'll finish that
second half of bacon and cheese at like
10 p.m i don't i've done that i'm okay
with it i've done the fatter
it's like a scab because it's on a bagel
you put a bagel in there
on that thing you put a bagel in the
fridge it's over exactly then you put it
back in the oven you got to get crisp on
it now see this is what i'm talking
about it's like what putting it back in
the oven
what are you nuts you guys what are you
emerald
tune in to not be [ __ ] stupid if you
want to learn something it'll be great
it is true i will say that uh
it is i i will make cat joey pepe yeah
dude yeah
he taught me how to make chocolate yeah
it's a dish dish it's like a famous
tuscan dish it's just three cat joey
pepe i don't like the fact you said
tuscany
yeah he meant something like three guys
you owe money to
you know fat joey and pepe
they run the book out of the bar we go
to
comey's stealing pint glasses it was his
dad
he passed it down there
he's the guy behind that rotunda beer
[ __ ] raven
looking for fat joey to catchy
tom i want 20 on the bed
[Laughter]
all right all right this is from andrew
first guys so as you know when you sign
up for patreon we will answer your
garbage questions it's just the best way
to do it we get hit up you know through
so many other ways but patreon gets
first cracking
um
this is from andrew first question long
time homie ever had to testify in court
in front of a jury
tommy i'm looking at you for some reason
my closest court situation was uh i got
hit in the face with a bottle
in the greatest bar
or something
and the kid got clipped coming back from
his honeymoon like three years later and
i had to go to the water press charges
yeah
and uh and on the way to court i called
my brother and my brother's like what
are you doing this kid
you're [ __ ] 23 years old three years
ago
you know three
i mean be vague then
yeah so apparently the guy out here was
december 24th 1980
dim the lights were
no it was a huge bar fight everything
was working perfectly the first three
guys i hit out it was [ __ ] beautiful
and i was like i was 190. i was like
another 30 pounds of [ __ ] muscle this
is like just after baseball
lifting heavy days for no goddamn reason
i'd stick some i was built like
spongebob squarepants i had tiny legs no
legs just but i was it went all up here
someone's not being specific
anyway i knocked a couple friends he was
wearing a blue shirt and the dude i'm
about 178 pounds right now maybe 170 out
of the shower i don't know
174. and then i got behind this one dude
and i took him off a friend and this
dude that i recognized because we were
down the shore together at a shore
shorehouse party and i was like go help
chris he was now he's bringing up a
second location
no it was a it was in roxboro that place
had three different layers
all right i think uh you've already
violated the terms of yours
i never testified in front of anyone but
i did tell the guy i'm not pressing
charges in the courthouse i had to be an
expert so i dropped all the charges and
the kid was like oh thank you so much
because it's like it's intent
with but this was three years after this
happened it was three years after the
bar fight because he they couldn't find
him
jesus and then he went on his honeymoon
when he came back in there came back in
you gotta get in here
they ran god damn really and then so i
know i'm clean if i came back into the
states yeah you're good there's nothing
there's no warrants nice yeah what do
you have to get arrested you think
pulled over
dangerous man
okay
toby i'm sorry i had like 17 coffees a
long story but i've been in court you're
doing great
[Music]
chris
i believe chris just said he was an
expert witness i was an expert witness
he's like i haven't been caught yet but
i will see my i will see my day do it in
court
find the body yeah yeah yeah once they
find her head under his clothes in his
bedroom
no yeah i was called i when my brother
was in law school i went down to visit
him in new orleans and uh
he was like can you be like a expert
witness in like moot court or whatever
it was like you know it was like kids
practicing
and i was like yes fine
and i went in there and like i i you
know i didn't i've read over like who i
was supposed to be for it's just a
script 20 minutes yeah but like i didn't
spend any time we're not talking about
some school play here
on the roof too all right
we're talking bottles to the face grand
jury
testimony yeah you got the balls that
cut me off for this
the story is over i hid in her car for
45 minutes while cops were around a
parking lot
some show your brother's sorority was
doing listen
zip it all right
jesus christ
talking about wiretaps and [ __ ]
charges
not the [ __ ] debate team
i thought it'd be a nice story
then we all got ice cream afterwards
they put up a hell of an argument they
did they were poking holes in my
testimony what am i gonna say no to free
pizza
i know the pizza and soda 100 there was
no ice cream no ice cream warm
temperature orange soda they would you
know they would cut it in a weird way to
get more mileage out of it
nothing pisses me off more than that
there was no pizza there was no
the guy [ __ ] cross-examined me
for 30 minutes he was 13. and i'm just
making [ __ ] up
and then he's like but you put in a
sworn affidavit and i had to be like
dude that's not my signature
[Laughter]
i'm not a real person yeah we're gonna
need to we're gonna need a handwriting
expert in here
he just puts a pair of glasses on that
is not my handwriting
it's a lady wearing a wig
[Laughter]
like [ __ ] bronson and uh what's his
face in bronson
oh man
you got a little john wayne in them i
like it
did your brother ever graduate did you
become a lawyer yeah your brother's a
lawyer yeah what kind of like practicing
like criminal wall or no no no mergers
and acquisitions or something uh yeah
it's like states and trusts and stuff
like that that's where the money is yeah
i think i think i think i'm not sure
actually
it's definitely not god damn it it was a
lefty under the lefty
what do you want from me
this one's great this is from thomas
ever gave yourself food poisoning
have you ever cooked something for
yourself before no you know who gave me
food poisoning though john o zelay
you know yeah
one time i let him cook me chicken i was
[ __ ] for i'm gonna say eight hours
straight
that's when you [ __ ]
yeah
that's when you poop in public no i
wasn't in public thank goodness yeah
you're hemmed up you're in a bed i just
rolled around it was like getting
stabbed in the gut all night no sleep
just get up [ __ ] get up [ __ ] i've done
i've done a thing where uh i was puking
and [ __ ] so much i just laid down in
the shower yeah that's a good move and
just [ __ ] and that's cold there's
nothing better than that and i would
just [ __ ] and puke and let it run down
the train
damn
livestock yeah and just i would just
hold myself down like a lamb giving
birth he's covered in goo
he's just crying [ __ ] and throwing up it
was happening so frequently and coming
out of both hands i was just like
[ __ ] probably going i got a piss get
out of there
he's probably jerking off again no no
that's why i was like living in my
apartment uh or an apartment with my
girlfriend i'm sure she was thrilled
yeah
how long after that did that end
i know it wasn't three years
really
women do love you for a long time yeah i
don't know why i got a little i got
something
i cooked fish one time and gave myself
into my madness
[Laughter]
and i'm gonna let you out there
hanging hanging high and dry
um
this is from josh carter yo big fan
first time question do either you do
does anybody have any visible cigarette
burns yeah i have one right here
on your hand i got one right somewhere
yeah here college would be cool kind of
thing
yeah one of these guys
yeah that's a nice one that's a held in
circle oh yeah on purpose why'd you go
to the most delicate part yeah you got
to go
i got a real bad one right there that
you can't really see too well but i got
it when i was real little the story is
are you trying to mock me you [ __ ]
what the story is is that i walked into
only you would take that like
he's been busting my balls about my long
stories and the way he dropped his wish
and this story he's also very crazy
[Laughter]
i was not mocking you sir
he's just feeling vulnerable about his
childhood
uh is that the the story is that i
walked into my aunt who had a cigarette
lit cigarette in your hand now
i think these aren't
connor cross examining you now
at the bottom is this your [ __ ]
signature
the
it's too
like
dead you think there was some intent did
you have a baby
i was like three a bad relationship oh i
didn't know how old you were you said
you were walking by her
kind of three-year-old's walking that
[ __ ] eye
yeah when i got your head not your arm
yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying and i don't
remember it it's before i can remember
oh she probably pissed her off somebody
put a cigarette butt out on me that's
what i i assume that's what happened
yeah that's licensed yeah you can see my
initials we get in high school in 1998
uh branded
yeah with a razor blade we all put our
last names on our i got like pa wait
with a hot razor blade or just cut
we just cut into our just cut with razor
blade
no i don't know we just got drunk at a
shore house in uh seattle and then we
just all were like let's do our initials
all right
oh connor you never do anything like
that right now i had a friend once turn
on
turn on megadeth and [ __ ] pierce his
nipples in high school i was just like
hanging out at his house and he was just
like uh and he started wiping the blood
on his face oh my god
jesus christ what the [ __ ] you're
hanging out with this guy there's a body
yours
[Music]
you ever have an amp like coming up like
steve wear my earrings like she goes to
a wedding once oh yeah
ah
vicious i assume you had your ears
pierced i got both pierced yeah well
what was it what did you have like the
diamond studs yeah i went diamonds that
was a big thing they also had gold hoops
at one time
did you ever have multiple earrings in
each ear yeah wow i did the hoops
multiples i went diamond solo one
diamond one diamond real diamond
oh kubrick's sarcone or some sharks what
kind of places where are you going
he also just say razor blade and [ __ ]
cut himself with his initials what what
kind of places where are you going dude
finger banging parties
fbps
i'm trying to every picture like dancing
nose no
nope penis nope
my buddy not even close i pierced his
eyebrow one time it was like eighth
grade or whatever where you know in his
room you just got looking for something
to do yeah he's like i want to pierce my
eyebrow
you know i'll do it myself in the
bathroom i'm like i'll [ __ ] you know
i'll do it thought i had the guts to do
it yeah so just heated up a seat like a
big safety pin
and i got through
i think i went up for i don't know what
i got through half damn then i don't
they clamp it like did you how did you
clamp oh i did i i didn't have the guts
to get like i got it oh so you like
yeah cause i'm like dude i'm [ __ ]
yeah i mean i'm throwing my [ __ ] hips
behind this thing and it's not coming up
yeah yeah so i pass it i'm out so i just
left it with
a whole safety them just hanging in his
head he's like someone's got to do it
someone's got to do it
you piece of [ __ ]
dude i'm squeamish where'd you hit
muscle what did you hit muscle or
something i don't know it just wasn't it
was just he's just squirmish was it it
was
[Laughter]
i bet he was more of a big mouth
[Laughter]
guy who wants his eyebrow pierced in the
basement that's [ __ ] yeah
i'm gonna run down and grab a sandwich
real quick
my dad's calling me just hangs a
christmas ball on the one end
i know you look good you look good yeah
you're fine
all right um let's see this from lewis
uh you ever live on the same block as a
decommissioned limousine
what the [ __ ] does that even live on the
same way where like someone has a limo
or does anybody in your neighborhood
it's not really a limousine no
she moved to the knee she was new in the
neighborhood that's kind of cool yeah it
wasn't not for a sixth grader
[Laughter]
yeah school buses like people get that
they come for like you know uh
tailgating
parties
what are you talking about in the best
circumstances yeah you painted eagles
green and you get a grill and yeah but
that's that's the one percent of
school bus owners my one buddy put it
painted his uh like a [ __ ] shitty
nissan like an 85 nissan bright orange
for the flyers frankie squirrel shout
out frank and then and then painted the
flyers logo on the front of his little
beater were they good that year or
something no i just think he's so
passionate i love linda ross
and this wasn't a tailgating car this is
like go to work car
gotta go to enter a enterprise
rent-a-car or whatever what if you get
fired for something like that if you had
like a business job and you were showing
up with a bright orange well he's not
doing door-to-door sales
i'm staying in the in the company who
would have happened to be a flyers fan
would you sir
who's your long-distance carrier at the
moment
have i already stopped by here
we had the ultimate trash uh somebody in
our neighborhood had a delorean and old
yes
dude no never
they never run no dude [ __ ] four flat
tires just sitting in the driveway
didn't matter everybody rolled by
this is the delorean
yeah is that trash i thought that was
cool when it does it's crazy [ __ ] yeah
that's cool yeah but it's like so that's
so much
that's someone probably
this is my thing with it
it's a project but the people who want
that to be a project never have they get
the money they're getting money and they
never have the operating capital
finished
right right 100 yeah they have no idea
what that entails as soon as they got
the car they're like it's all downhill
from here uh-huh we have the car and it
just sits there for years and then they
sell and get their
oh yeah yeah yeah so the landscaping is
always tough on the back side of those
yeah one time my big aunt split the back
of the chair at thanksgiving just
explode into like matchsticks you can't
bounce back from that no a broken chair
yeah her name's laurie which is a beefy
name to start
what is it she's a little thicker yeah
lori
that's it you come out you come out of
the womb with a meat wagon with your
name you got some hips on you as soon as
that name goes on a [ __ ] birth
certificate
it's like nutty professor yeah you smell
right
it's not a forgiving name
[Music]
it's like maggie like [ __ ] like that you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
beef bag names immediate yeah there's
some hot maggies out there though very
hot baggies yeah yeah there is curly
hair
you said that like one god like the one
that got it
i know a maggie
curly hair get out of the trunk i feel
like hot maggies have curly hair yeah
they do probably
never seen one
all look like linebackers
oh my god all right let's do one more
and wrap it up this has been a heater
what is this three three questions
four or five maybe okay all right it's
got 15 20 minutes of questions yeah yeah
that's good yeah
uh this is from lee ever book a hotel
room with cash yeah of course of course
you have yeah well i mean yeah i didn't
have any credit i know i still i mean
what did you have to put down because
that happened to me once i used to have
to go to i forget but i used to have to
go to um
uh what's the
walmart not walmart what's the sears
shittiest walgreens department store
k-mart
yeah it was either came on or something
but i had to pay back uh a debt
uh using to clean up your credit to
clean up my credit so i had to pay that
with cash as well oh like everything was
cash because i couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't afford a card you had to go to
a walmart to pay a bill you paid a bill
in the store it was through this uh
what's the pay process it's jesus christ
i don't remember any of this it was like
15. yeah but yeah i paid so i had to pay
in cash for for hotels and [ __ ] like if
i want to take a girl a red roof in
after going off the irish pub after
winning a halloween contest that's what
i did
halloween contest what was the outfit or
costume my boy were
were tetris pieces really intense about
halloween for like three four years
jesus christ and uh we're in his his
parents basement
it's so important when you're like 24
yeah or whatever yeah yeah yeah it's
like 20 for those years 20 21 22 your
identity for a
so uh this one year uh we couldn't
figure out what we wanted to be and
we're like [ __ ] we used to go to
davis's trading post like and then just
like walk around find something and we
go back to his parents uh basement and
we're just [ __ ] scratching our heads
and he looks over and he's like i
[ __ ] got it
dude i got it and he i could i could
tell he had a good one he looks behind
the couch he goes look and it's a
full-size white siberian tiger
this is like two weeks maybe one week
after siegfried and roy got bit oh
so important maybe sig freedom roy so we
go to davis's trading post and we just
get two
um what are they paying you or something
it's the same time you mentioned davis's
trading post no this is the best place
to go i don't know what it is either
delco delco lights will understand like
when my mom mentions the five and dime
i'm like i don't know what you're
talking about secret
one-piece suits like elvis suits i get
black he gets white
and it's full-sized tigers so he he's
obviously the guy that gets bit so he
ties the tiger around it i i it would be
dragon he was he's six four and then he
gets the neck wound he's got all the
things all the accessories that are fun
i mean i just look like a [ __ ] when
he goes to the bathroom i'm just you
look like a people i'm a gay ouch
i'm a bg yes but the prize money was 700
700
so what they did was they walked around
there was like
whatever their hosts were the judges
they were walking 102
you're in the top ten and then it was
mob dude nuts to butts you couldn't
[ __ ] slide anywhere
so we go in the back and they parade you
around
on top of the bar in the back they pick
the top five the top five would stand on
the bar and walk all the way to the end
of the bar and the dude would put his
hand over each one and crowd there was
like 300 people
it was my first kill
because by the time they got to us first
it was halloween at the irish
he started crying
he was so happy and laughing so hard
they get to before they could even get
to us we're on the the fifth on the end
the entire place is chanting siegfried
and roy siegfried and roy and then they
put on this like this music he starts
doing the [ __ ] billy madison the pony
dance down the other end of the bar back
and forth
and then we uh we met a couple ladies
because you know yeah and then i went to
the red roof inn paid a little cash
and had that was the worst next day uh
what he called walk of shame
a sequin suit coming out of the red roof
with a bloody stuffed tiger
no he had the tiger we split ways
holy [ __ ] oh my god these two are crazy
that's kind of crazy
that's a good one that's a good one
that's a good one
that is a good one that's a human
experience
you having a good time yeah yeah i've
never gotten laid from a costume before
what were your halloween costumes and
like
jesus christ
yeah i think i was the dude one year
who's big lebowski from little bouncers
okay yeah
it's just his neighbor dude i i've never
had a good costume again it's it's like
cooking
to be honest yeah it's like
it was it was big that was always gossip
boys we absolutely love you i love you
stop filing this podcast patreon's
cooking yeah you're gonna be doing a
cooking show we're also doing he filmed
me cutting my hair because people are
interested how to how to cut their own
hair so we're gonna do like stupid [ __ ]
like that those two it is impressive
they're just at some point it's gonna be
a 24 7 live stream of their them just
hanging out in their house
pay for it you get it
top tier members wednesday nights
wednesday nights we do live stream us
playing uh oculus surprisingly [ __ ]
fun it's [ __ ] really fun
he was giving me the metaverse rundown
where i was just like uh yeah i was like
i don't get it oh you're gonna be big in
the meadow
he's already killed three people
hanging upside down bleeding out they're
[ __ ] and puking in doves
you live on some far-off spaces yeah
thank you guys thank you guys
i absolutely love you what do you got
for him guys check out the [ __ ]
special our live show the middle class
famous tour is on sale right now we're
going to hartford albany syracuse
[ __ ] atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rosemont the whole nine at
cameron comedy on social media check it
out and we'll be adding more dates to
that we love you guys and we'll see you
next week peace